To understand what's happening with Greece
and the Eurozone, think about a dinner party.
If you're cooking just for yourself and your
spouse, it's easy: you make something you
both like. But if you've got guests, things
get harder. If you need to accommodate a vegetarian,
and someone who is gluten free, and someone
with a soy allergy, your options get really
limited. And that's the problem with Europe's
idea of having a whole bunch of countries
all use the same currency. So Greece's economy
is in a disaster. A quarter of the population
is unemployed, and it has this very high debt
burden. Normally, if you've got really high
unemployment, what happens is that a country
makes its currency cheaper by printing extra
money. That makes its products cheaper on
world markets, it makes it a more attractive
tourist destination, and it means that foreign
investors can get great bargains. But if unemployment
is really low, a country likes to have an
expensive currency. That increases people's
purchasing power and it keeps prices down.
And in Europe, you have a bunch of economies
that are really different. A price of Euros
that's appropriate for Greece, where they
have a 25% unemployment rate is way too low
for Germany, where the unemployment rate is
below 5%. And Greece's problem is that it's
small, poor, and geographically isolated from
the rest of the Eurozone. It's like the only
vegetarian at a barbeque, except when it comes
to currencies, there's no side dishes. And
so there's plenty of specific decisions we
can second-guess, plenty of things Greece
did and various banks did that we can question,
but fundamentally having all these countries
come to a dinner party with only one dish
on the menu was a mistake. The euro was a
project that Europe set about on for really
political reasons. It was a symbol of their
determination to have peace on the continent,
but they didn't really take the economics
of it seriously. So Greece joins the euro
in 2001 and initially, it works out great
for Greece because all of a sudden everyone
was like 'yeah, sure, let's lend them money.'
So they borrowed lots and lots and lots of
euros, except that didn't change the fact
that their economy is a lot weaker than some
of the other European countries. So to really
work, you would need a much, much, much closer
union, where you had big financial transfers
coming from the richer places to the poorer
places all the time. In the United States,
the poor states like Kentucky, Mississippi,
Alabama, they're constantly getting money
from the richer states like Massachusetts,
California, New York, through the welfare
system, through Social Security, through Medicare,
through Medicaid. And you know, people may
complain about this or that program, but we
don't dispute the idea that it's all one country
so money is going to circulate around. Europeans,
you know, they just don't feel that way. Germans
are willing to support poor German people,
but they don't want to support Greek people
with their tax dollars. So they're kind of
like half-way integrated in a way that doesn't
really work.